je reçois maintenant la cinéaste
catherine breillat pour la sortie
mercredi en salles de romance une
comédie de moeurs dans laquelle breillat
film crûment la quête de quéquette d'une
jeune femme est prise mais apprendre
catherine breillat bonsoir à ce qui est
bien et puis ce qu'on peut faire des
vannes est alors revendre une sortie le
14 avril alors l'argument
du film donc c'est paul qui est jouée
par sagamore stévenin qui repousse mari
qui est jouée par caroline ducey vous
dit deux choses à ce niveau là vous
dites l'amour courtois plus le sexe
c'est seulement au moment de la
rencontre en général après ça passe très
vite ça après ça oui enfin bon les
généralités c'est aussi un film c'est à
dire que c'est aussi l'histoire d'une
jeune fille s'apprêtant pas apporté
toutes les réponses
finalement à des questions que moi même
je me pose donc ça c'est juste la mort
qu'on doit plus le sait que ça dure pas
très très loin il est dans une relation
du début la soul et au charme elle puis
puis en revanche je vous dit quelque
chose qui que nous les mecs on sait pas
vous dites c'est aux femmes que l'amour
physique manque le plus à vous tous âges
de valence oui ils ont pensé que nous on
était des cochons et que toutes les
filles étaient pure et c'est ça fait
plaisir mais non je pense pas qu'elle
fasse ça pour vous faire plaisir mais je
pense que quand vous êtes des cochons
c'est à dire que finalement le côté je
ne peux pas bander pour ma femme donc
laure et le réveil en fanfare le viagra
pour amender en disant à sa femme n'ont
pas je t'aime mes [ __ ] voudra
peut-être qu'elles ont qu'elles ont de
la gentillesse envers vous c'est bien
alors donc malgré ces malgré tous les
efforts qu'elle fait et dieu sait si
elle en fait notre amie caroline là il
la baisse pas donc elle décide de partir
dans une espèce durant un voyage
initiatique une descente en enfer qui en
fait se trouve être une rédemption
puisque en fait elle l'enfermé pas dans
le segment longtemps à nous le faire
croire oui moi je crois que c'est vrai
que les les émotions physique et qu'on
me prouve par les émotions sexuelle
c'est quelque chose qui nous transporte
complètement et je pense que justement
il ya peut-être une très très grande
différence entre la jouissance physique
de l'homme qui est très matérielle
dignement et on qui est de l'ordre de la
petite mort et la jouissance qui vivent
de la femme qui est de l'ordre du
ravissement
oui mais bon moi c'est quelque chose que
je m'entendais très bien mais c'est vrai
qu'on peut dire c'est un film qui est
plus mystique que pornographiques quand
on l'a vu quand on relit dect ans quand
on lit des articles dans les journaux on
s'attend qu'à la pornographie est une
industrie arbitraire voilà qui a été
décidé au moment où les metteurs en
scène comme on sait justement à montrer
à la fois le sexe est l'âme réunis ce
qui était beau le cadre de l' empire des
sens et tout d'un coup on crée de toutes
pièces une industrie par l'interdît puis
saint jean soit argent soit donc c'est
vrai que le film est comme je disais
plus mystique que pornographiques et
vous dites et vous avez raison la
jouissance de la femme appartient au
sacré cirque en fait c'est vrai qu'une
femme qui qui jouit avec vous dites une
lumière séraphique sur le visage oui ça
c'est vrai puis ça peut se filmer il ya
une espèce d'aura ya une lumière qui
vient de l'intérieur bon et j'ai trouvé
je pense une jeune actrice qui est
absolument extraordinaire parce que si
je puis dire est la presse que cette
lumière qui en appelle des lumières
divines qui vient tout le temps et
c'était le grand était nécessaire de mon
chef opérateur parce que le film doit
beaucoup aussi à ce chef opérateur qui a
travaillé avec theo angelopoulos
longtemps regarde à netease bien sûr et
je lui disais mais tu vois une actrice
bien sûr qu'il faut l'éclairer me faut
aussi qu'elles c'est clair tout seul et
c'est quand même le but de la vie des
gens terre qu'on est des gens et 1 on a
peur de notre corps des enfants n'ont
pas ça ils ont la lumière et je pense
que les adultes sont mal à l'aise
transforme tout le sexe est une chose
presque désastreuse finalement vous
dites que vous détestez vous avez une
vraie haine pour la l'éducation
judéo-chrétienne amis c'est clair oui
ajoute vidéo chrétienne islamistes tuent
vélo chrétiens apprentis charia oui
c'est les trois grandes religions
finalement monothéistes qui je pense bon
n'ont pas pour but parce qu'elles ont
pris le pouvoir temporel d'élever
l'homme mai d'abaisser la facture
qu'elles ont fait les religions
monothéistes ont fait de dieu un homme
et la femme est un ventre en fait dans
un ventre et puis il faut la préserver
dans sa dignité ce qui semble dire qu'il
n'en a pas c'est tout le problème de la
censure le problème de la censure et de
la morale érigé comme ça comme quelque
chose qui est comme un garde chiourme de
quelque chose qui serait donc abjecte et
cette abjection je crois qu'elle pèse
oui c'est sûr mais dans des blessures
mais une barrière c'est quelque chose à
protéger quelque chose qui pouvait en
fait n'existe pas quelque chose à
protéger parce que je pense que le tabou
il interdit
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut protéger
mais qu'il faut transgresser c'est donc
une porte
si cette porte on l'a mur on nous
cantonne dans l'enfance est bien
contente dans le ventre dites moi vous
n'êtes pas dans le film soit s'est vendu
un peu comme le fasse et vendus s'est
présenté dix ans comme le premier porno
d'auteur est en fait à l'arrivée bon il
ya quelques scènes évidemment mais qui
sont pas je dire faut pas aller voir ce
film pour bander un blessé pour se
reconnaître vous avez dit
bon vous avez pas peur vous dites aussi
je suis de marchands de tapis vous dites
ça dans le magazine première
est ce que le magazine première vous
voulez moi que je vous tends d'un
appareil de photo jetable que je vous
dise
allez faire la photo dans l'intimité ils
ont demandé de faire une photo en baisse
et des pâtes parade dans ma trio là
quand vous n'avez pu dire oui on était
aux côtés du marchand de tapis vous êtes
quelqu'un qui a fait un film qui a envie
qui se vantent bon que les gens aient le
voir jusque là pas de problème de
l'argent c'est le mal et on en reparlera
après le mal que vous avez eue dans
votre carrière j'espère un truc qui vous
a prié une semaine vous avez commencé on
sait le mal que vous avez eue après
tapage nocturne on dirait un mot tout à
l'heure mais est-ce que vous avez pas
peur que finalement ce film qui est
vendu comme le premier porno d'auteur
les gens vont aller le voir en disant il
ya même pas la scène de de pénétration
voit pas le sexe de rocco qui on le voit
mais revoit pas pénétrer beaucoup mieux
rocourt la loi bon prendre aux cautions
voit pas la pénétration croit croco
c'était le thème de l'effroi il est venu
sur le plateau tout le monde avait peur
oui ça y paraît qu'une chose tout le
monde était convié à la théorie oui mais
finalement lui qui n'a aucun tabou il a
fini par en avoir un c'est la perte de
son identité de son âme
et tout d'un coup au lieu de faire une
scène de sexe ce qu'il a fait dans mille
un secret le mil deuxième je veux dire
je n'avais pas envie de faire ça ce que
j'avais envie de montrer ça il me l'a
donnée il est sublime c'est cet homme
qui est le plus grand étalon du on de
finalement et bien qui est le plus
faible qui est devant caroline et qui
finalement n'a qu'une seule chose c'est
qu'il la supplique elle est peut-être le
moment il lui met la main enfin pendant
le tournage je lui met la main sur la
cuisse et soir je veux dire c'était très
très long ça a duré huit heures et là
huit minutes donc mais c'est le moment
de ces huit minutes que j'appelle la
prise magique le reste ce sont des
trépassés la confidentielle si vous
tournez beaucoup de pression non
j'entende pas beaucoup mais là je
pensais qu'il fallait en tournée
beaucoup parce qu' il fallait pas qu'ils
soient qu'ils pensent
il fait des comptes ans travaille et
qu'on avait tout le temps et qu'on ne
ferait qu'une chose d'extraordinaire et
que donc le cinéma c'est pas du
happening c'est-à-dire qu'ils disent que
cela va jusqu'au bout de n'importe quoi
les acteurs ne stimule pas il faut bien
qu'ils aient des ne simule pas leurs
émotions ils sont pas obligés de
mais on peut simuler une pénétration
caroline stimule bien d'autres choses
dans le film tout à fait alors
d'ailleurs je ne poserait pas la
question en tout cas elle dit qu'il ya
eu pénétration lui dit cui je vais pas
vous demander c'est un c'est pas monica
elle n'est pas stagiaire à la maison
gérée qu'elle est actrice à la maison
réponse dans le casting noyer rocco
siffredi alors vous vouliez prendre
xavier beauvois il n'a pas voulu alors
je parle trop sûrement cette chose qui
m'énerve quand on fait un film on a
plein de directions de daisy normal et
puis ses désirs tout mais dites moi et
xavier moi j'adore vous aviez de
babouins mais non il va pas réellement
dit non mais à un moment je disais est
ce que tu te rends compte vraiment et
caetera et puis je sais d'avancé mais
j'adore je dis vous avez parlé de rocco
avec des larmes dans la voix vous dit
que il n'est pas mécanique sur caen les
hommes obèses souvent c'est des machines
à coudre vie vous dit il comme un signe
il est pas mécanique il et vibratoires
c'est vrai alors comme j'avais lu ça
quand j'ai vu le film j'ai regardé
essais mais qu'il ondule comme ça c'est
pas celle inverse de la machine à coudre
donné raison s'est bien vu vous avez la
wii est d'accord même on se dit que des
hommes qui nous font l'amour doivent
plus ressembler à roko quand ils font
l'amour
quand donc aux acteurs des films pornos
qui font que des prouesses techniques
quoi alors
caroline donc vous l'avez quand même mis
dans un univers
tu as droit de rentrer chez elle elle
était elle vivait le soir tous les
filles il faut quand même rentré en film
au début on commence un film commence
incarné dans un personnage comment même
moi me dire que je suis metteur en scène
au début je veux dire le premier moment
c'est un art magique le cinéma donc
c'est quelque chose qui est un petit peu
sacré où il faut se transformer les
vandales et non mais c'est pas du tout
mais l'erika les rentrées rentrer dans
le chou ça qu'il rentrait chez elle le
soir ça casse et la magie était plus
dans le film alors dites-moi berléand
françois berléand qui qui fait du
bondage avec notre amie caroline là
c'est vraiment ça c'est quand même à
quoi vous les proposer à godard le rôle
et la refuser je lui propose la gaude
argile proposé à plein d'autres
appareils tout le monde a envie de
godard pascal godart le verbe il aurait
été bien que godard n'a bien sûr pas mal
surtout cher oui chercher sa dépendance
à l'an dernier on est venu chez moi
c'était lui ça mais aucun des autres à
qui j'avais b
dans tous les cas berland et on ne voit
pas trop la sur la promo pour ela et lab
était pas content d'avoir fait ce non
c'est pas ça je pense qu'effectivement
il ya un grand désir des médias qui se
vendent très bien avec rocco siffredi
donc c'est leur problème et que
effectivement dans le film il ya une
énorme révélation outre caroline c'est
effectivement perdu en quarts quel
acteur faire qu'ils la tâche avec des
cordes c'est une chose mais il attache
avec des mots là il dévide de presse de
choses qu'aucun acteur au monde n'a
jamais tout à fait alors on va avancer
sinon n'est jamais arrivé donc je dirais
qu'il ya 3 3 hondschoote et leers os
votre film naoshima a bientôt puisque
l'an pire d'essence et un film qui vous
a beaucoup marqué il ya courbet je
dirais l'origine du monde parce que
c'est comme ça que ça se termine sur qu
elle devient femme fois de tafer mercure
une ouverture symbolique comme ça de la
confiance parce que avec le ciseau
entendent d'oise ou doré voilà un oeil à
christine pascal votre ami vous avez
travaillé avec elle dans tapage nocturne
devait aider sur félicité ah non je vais
l'aider je la connaissais pas avant
on s'est connus c'est ce que j'appelle
une amie de cinéma cette année on s'est
connus par nos films qui nous ont parlé
de nous comme ça qu'on est deux
mes amis je dirais à la vie à la mort
est alors catherine meyer est née à new
york est la ville des assurances
certainement gay niort que clouzot a
décidé d'y tourner des diabétiques va
toujours elle s'est toujours pensé que
c'était par hasard c'était un signe
presque une vie aussi étriqué aussi
étroite dans laquelle on vous tient sous
pression ouais c'est peut-être
formidable parce que j'ai employé comme
ça si vous n'avez pas vécu là bas je
suis à lui autant de livres je ne serai
pas forgée dans l'imaginaire alors vous
dites niort c'est l iran il y avait un
trottoir pour les filles un trottoir
pour les garçons c'est donc alors j'ai
été amené le tas de trottoirs des
garçons faisant défaut mais j'imagine ce
que vous deviez être un sacré pistolet
parce que d'abord vous étés pubères très
jeune avec votre soeur marie hélène vous
aviez les chevrons les cheveux pardon
teints en blond platine et vous étiez
quand même vous devez être quelqu'un
dans votre adolescence mans j'étais je
pense que le problème de vouloir
soumettre comme ça et réduire c'est que
ou fort jolie des inverse
l'inde réduite soumis devient soumis et
devient lui même ce qui est pas le
problème des hommes parce que comme les
hommes on leur donne une place dominante
finalement qui est un masque qu'ils ont
de la peine à tenir ce que la
parabolique six mois sagamore coc sur la
pointe des pieds pour paraître un homme
et bien c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
se remettre en question et c'est
beaucoup plus difficile d'avoir
l'opposition contre ce masque est d'être
alors donc vous avez quand même eu
malgré tout ça le bac a le bac à 16 ans
avec deux ans d'avancé avec mention bien
j'ai plutôt bien et alors vous mentez à
paris et là je sais pas si nos amis
téléspectateurs le ca mais vous avez
écrit à 17 ans un livre qui étaient
interdits aux moins de 18 ans déjà donc
qui s'appelait l'homme facile que un
certain succès à 12 ans déjà écrit et
libanais oui non c'était pas 12 ans
c'était juste avant après et écrit des
livres des scénars effet des films c'est
parce qu'on vit est hélas pas nouveau
tout ça vous avez fait des scénarii pour
fellini pour pia la police et une
histoire d'ailleurs pour christine
pascal zanzibar alors vous avez fait
d'essayer un scénario pour hamilton
c'est au café le seigneur de ville était
fait mais je ne savais pas ça on est
alors en 76 vous faites votre premier
film s'appelle une vraie jeune fille
d'après un roman avoue que ça plaît le
soupirail
il a bon j'ai fait plein de films et
c'est ce qu'on me disait tout à l'heure
tu dire que votre carrière ne vous
laissez pas par hasard quoi je veux dire
en 79 ou fait tapage nocturne avec
dominique la fin ça marche pas très bien
les ça marche et ça marchait tapage
nocturne la seule chose c'est que les
gens n'étaient pas préparés le recevoir
c'est à dire qu'ils entraînent sûrement
le fou le plus de gens au nom de sortait
et si j'avais dit que j'étais le metteur
en scène y avait du lynchage dans l'est
parce que parce que ça parlait de la
liberté d'une femme déjà c'était
pourtant demi que la fin c'est un
personnage très proche de la baie des
anges non mais c'était intolérable
alors donc vous faites ce film arrive et
déjà quand même parce que là vous avez
pris rocco siffredi y avait quand même
déjà joe dallesandro dans tapage
nocturne qui est une égérie de la
factory de warhol qui était un petit un
petit musclé comme ça ils rament keller
dans c'est vrai c'est bien pourquoi on
fait comme ses producteurs qui engagent
des jolies starlettes dans l'est dans
les films booth et les hommes dont vous
êtes resté là huit ans éloigné des
plateaux jusqu'à 36 36 fillette pardon
ou là vous l'avez est obligé d'écrire
plusieurs fois le scénario pour à votre
avance sur recette surveiller d'écrire
un bouquin oui absolument
ouais non sap a été semé la dernière
question je vais vous poser c'est
quand vous êtes quand vous tournez vous
vous cachez comme ça sous une espèce de
comme on dit pour les enfants la jeune
on je me cache pas sans une espèce de
petit un foulard foulard mais comme ça
aura déjà là et normalement j'ai la
frange qui va juste là juste là il passe
comme ça et c'est quoi ça ben si ça
c'est facile expliqué c'est parce que en
fait moi je vais à dans l'extrême
extrême extrêmes limites de la vérité du
jeu des acteurs comme ça ce que
j'appelle la prise magique on retient
son souffle et on est si troublés parce
que ça ressemble à de la vérité d'où les
questions aussi par le maroc aussi vous
laisser ressemble tellement à de la
vérité que je suis la première à être
complètement confuse et donc cette
confusion
j'ai besoin de concentration parce que
faire un film c'est un état de
concentration de sans transcendance de
pouvoir immatériel sur les ans pour voir
ce que c'est que le pouvoir d'un metteur
en scène et à pouvoir les gens du coin
carolina était prête à tout vous donner
la wii c'est à pouvoir d'hypnotiseur et
quand moi je suis comme tout le monde
j'ai peur du regard des autres immeubles
détruits
donc j'ai pas peur d'être ridicule en
cachant parce que je suis concentré là
aussi je roule ni si j'ai des émotions
personne ne les voit qu'elles pensaient
qu'il y en a mais personne ne le sait
très bien
bah écoutez je vous remercie beaucoup
voilà c'est un quart d'heure oui ça
passe assez vite finalement dans cette
forme et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de inhabituel abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu